so i just want to record an update video
i know i've been a little bit absent
from youtube in the recent days and
weeks i was not kidnapped by monkeys i
was not arrested and sent to some prison
i just took a break and for those who
follow my channel closely when i was uh
uploading content in gibraltar you'll
know that i played a very serious
tournament it was a battle of the sexes
and i did record the first five recap
videos of my games
and
then
midway through the tournament i got
really wrapped up with preparing
seriously for every game
and
just didn't find the time and energy to
record recap videos
i realized that i'm not like a super
human robot type being
and i figured that it was better to
just conserve energy for my chess games
out of all the games i played they
averaged
uh over four hours per game i had a lot
of a lot of interesting battles and i do
plan to finish the recap videos and
share
the interesting and hopefully
instructive games that i did have
against some of the top female players
in the world so i do look forward to
doing that so after gibraltar i was
drained and i was still traveling too
uh spent several days traveling through
the uk
stopped in london and i was just a
little bit burnt out
um now i did manage to do a few fun
things in london i went to the stafford
london hotel
which is right next to buckingham palace
had some afternoon tea there and it was
just an amazing experience
and also went to the chess and bridge
shop the owners recognized me and gave
me a free chess set which is amazing
highly recommend checking them out link
will be in the description
and then i stopped at a local chess
meetup it was a london community chess
club it was super fun i walked in and a
bunch of people recognized me wanted to
play me
the organizer of the club gave me a
a nice mug which i will be using
and yeah if you want to check them out
if you're in london ever and um and want
to find a great group of people to play
chess with links will be in the
description there are other clubs and
meetups that reached out to me but
unfortunately i
my stay in london wasn't too long
so
i do hope to return at some point in the
near future it is one of my favorite
cities and then i came back to the us i
was jet lagged for a few days
i visited my parents who recently got a
new puppy
uh this is roxy she is just 10 months
old
tons of energy i spent a lot of time
just playing with her and trying to
teach her some basic tricks
also teach her some some main line
opening theory but that didn't go as
well
i spent a little bit too much time
playing ball with her in the snow and
then i came down with a cold and that
lasted for the last few days
but thankfully i'm uh pretty much fully
recovered
and for those wondering i did take uh
three covet tests in the span of like a
week and i tested negative so i think it
was just a basic hold
and thankfully i am feeling
motivated and re-energized and uh
i'm looking forward to recording song
or youtube content more chess content so
the last thing i want to mention in this
video i did start uploading my full
twitch streams to youtube it's on the
eric rosen extra channel and there has
been a steady stream of content
over the recent uh days and weeks so
maybe i haven't taken a full break from
youtube but i think only the uh the
super fans know about this channel so
again thanks for watching and i look
forward to seeing you in my next video
which will include some chess so stay
tuned